[Music]
is karl anthony towns underrated
gets it back ah
look at him look what i did look what
you did to that t-rex
[Music]
welcome to underrated the only show that
improves the video game ratings of your
favorite professional athletes today
that's carl anthony towns two-time
all-star let's go to our professional 2k
gamer davis to see how he stacks up in
the game
paul anthony towns demands a superstar
me personally when i look for someone
that can rebound strong handle the rock
just a little bit and can definitely
spread the floor and hit the open passer
when the double team comes to post
[Music]
i was looking at your rate
the one that stuck out to me
is your passing rate i think you're a
pretty good passer i appreciate it i've
seen it i've seen what are you 4.5
assists last year yeah i mean you're
like one below d'angelo russell what do
you think your passer rating was do you
notice
as a big man they always kind of put it
down a little bit sure so i would
probably say like
high 70s high 70s what if i were to tell
you carl anthony towns that it is
60. 60 what just a nope just a flat 60.
this is the wonderful the illuminary the
the prescient ronnie 2k everybody
you have a problem with that passing
right here let's fix it
you have my eyeballs
let's see we sat ronnie and his
beautiful brain in a room and we came up
with some drills okay and so the first
drill that we have is to improve that
passer rating and i think we can improve
it a bunch yeah we could get it up if he
performs really poorly though could it
also go down of course okay sure
hit a camera guy in the back of the head
that i think that would make it sued i
think that could be worse than the radio
let's challenge the assumption that
great insurance is only available at
high rates while cat gets a chance to
challenge the assumption that a big man
can't dish the ball
here's how this is gonna work okay i
want you to drive the lane and i don't i
don't want you to take it easy
i want like a game speed drive and then
a kick out and we're gonna do it three
times and the target's gonna get smaller
each time
what are you looking for
i mean he this is very important to him
i expect precision okay
if you really hate your 60 rating now is
the chance okay whenever you're ready
that was a good pass though it was a
good pass so this is where it was
stepped up
oh
did you see that yeah i it was i didn't
even hit any part of the white that was
the only thing that got hit whenever
you're ready all right
there we go here we go
oh
drilled it there wasn't a doubt in his
mind he's got a [ __ ] he's just staring
me
he's down staring at ronnie right now
you got him alone just didn't move are
you intimidated uh i mean he didn't even
touch the pole that was as clean as it
gets
very impressed yeah congratulations
gonna be honest though we went back and
talked about it we need to see a longer
pass so we're gonna do the opposite
which is instead of finishing a break
starting a break okay we're gonna do
some outlet passes
down here
all the way out here okay
let's see what you got
all right carl outlet passes three
two
one
[Music]
oh that was pretty cool is that
considered a hit i mean he said hit it
he did hit it that's pretty close i mean
the man baseball
randy johnson the ball right there now
it is time for basketball on basketball
cry
[Music]
fatality
finish him that was impressive well done
well done
[Music]
you have made it very difficult for us
not to reconsider that rating that was
impressive appreciate you the rating is
going up guaranteed yeah for sure the
amount that it's going up i feel like
the 70
is a no doubter
congratulations next up we have for you
though is rebounding okay cool the worm
rating
her anthony thomas definitely needs his
one batch upgraded the worm batch is
necessary for getting rebounds in 2k all
right and him having it at bronze is
absolutely ridiculous we've already seen
his football we already know he can make
a position for himself in the paint and
do everything that started to get the
rebound so 2k why is his warm badge only
on bronze
the reason we're doing this is because
you have a bronze worm rating
so this is your opportunity to upgrade
that i've been top five and rebounding
like every year that's what they've been
in right
that's what ronnie i know
we have uh some obstacles for you
they're a little prehistoric here's how
this is gonna work carl we're gonna have
a shooter from the top of the key okay
he's gonna put up five shots okay the
ball can only hit the ground in the
entire drill four times okay
if you're able to do that
bronze silver
badging up yo are you ready yo okay
[Music]
all right okay first one
[Music]
oh
you got your back ah
look at him look what i get look what
you did to that t-rex one move
he looks like he forget worm that's
bruiser right there they they extinct
again
you just made them extinct they should
have stayed down
two down
two bounces both very impressive
and he's ready no bounce
and the dunk
i love it
man get yourself up come on we got two
modes
damn slow
fourth shot
knocks it out that's
did that that only that ball hit the
ground that time did it nope
so one shot
ready
one two gets it no bounds
your official thoughts
i'm very very impressed
how did it feel man it was good you know
ronnie got to be proven wrong again so i
had to come out here put tie my shoes on
and then you know
he tried to do everything he tried to
give me a beach ball trying to give me a
target try to give me another basketball
that was some inception and then you
took it up to a baseball yeah right and
then and then he gave me some
prehistoric animals i mean that was
impressive uh you could just tell over
there uh undoubtedly
no doubter he's a silver so today your
passing went up 10 points
you went up a badge in terms of the worm
and now is my favorite thing to do is to
put ronnie on the spot
is karl anthony towns underrated with
everything i saw absolutely absolutely
underrated
my man he said it help me now you look
good
and that's why we do underrated karl
anthony towns underrated congratulations
you